fear not because once again joe is
giving you his word as a biden watch
this
even in this moment
with all the challenges we face
i give you my word as abide and i've
never been more optimistic about
america's future oh really during his
five-decade career in the washington
swamp lying has been a way of life for
joe biden but his most recent pledge to
unify the country might be his worst
fabrication of all time remember this
to restore the soul and secure the
future of america
requires so much more than words
requires the most elusive of all things
in a democracy
unity
unity
do you want to be the sign the side of
dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be on the side of john
lewis or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis my whole soul
is in this
bringing america together
uniting our people united in our nation
and i ask every american to join me in
this cause it is the most pernicious
thing this makes jim crow look like jim
eagle we can see each other not as
adversaries but as neighbors
we can treat each other with dignity and
respect
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid son of a [ __ ] you can
join forces
stop the shouting and lower the
temperature
there's thousands of people
in america going through that
and these republicans ripped that out of
the bill but we're coming back
we must end this uncivil war
that pits red against blue trump and the
extreme maga republicans have made their
choice
to go backwards full of anger violence
hate and division
well there you go joining us now fox
news contributor charlie hurt former
governor of arkansas mike huckabee and
fox news contributor deroy murdock
gentlemen thank you uh charlie uh look
you've been watched a lot of uh
presidents so we've been around for a
lot of elections uh there's a lot of
things that have been said by people all
the time that we don't like uh would you
agree that this is really unprecedented
and it strikes me as also almost hoping
someone's going to tip over
and something's going to start some kind
of spark is going to be lit what is your
take on this
well first of all the speech
i've never seen such an angry rancid
speech in which a president attacks the
voters that he supposedly works for i've
never seen anything like it it's uh and
and it's also very senseless because you
know at another point in the speech he
starts talking about how this is not
normal and uh we heard that a lot during
the four years of
trump's first term and but what's kind
of weird about this is well my goodness
democrats control the white house in
both chambers of congress if it's not
normal maybe you should look at yourself
maybe that's the problem but but tammy i
think i'm ter
and it's kind of funny i was calculating
this in my mind before we went on
whether i would even say something like
this but i'm afraid you're right if i
were to be completely honest about it i
think he is doing everything he can to
gin up something so that people do get
out of hand and that's a terrifying
thing to contemplate and it's a
terrifying thing to contemplate a
president trying to do that to in order
to benefit himself ahead of an election
in which he's going to get punished for
gas prices inflation an open border and
crime those are the issues that people
care about right and you know i deroy we
spent the summer of 2020 dealing with
violence and
riots uh a group
uh of course laughingly calling itself
uh anti-fascists
were the ones that were involved a great
deal in this and yet here now we have
that same sort of rhetoric saying now
that trump voters are semi-fascist
and seemingly linking to this history of
violence that all of us decry that none
of us want uh is this something that you
know he did he alluded to that there was
one sentence of like violence is never a
tool we can use almost as though to you
know get it out of the way uh what do
you think joe biden expects to happen
when rhetoric like this is used
well i think i could take this rhetoric
a lot more seriously if i'd heard it
earlier i remember during the democrat
convention in 2020 i listened carefully
for any denunciation of black lives
matters violence the antifa riots the
so-called summer of love and i didn't
hear that coming out of george joe
biden's mouth out of kamala harris's
mouth or anything else
i didn't hear much
comment from joe biden when a assassin
was walking around walking around on the
lawn of supreme court justice brett
kavanaugh with a glock pistol i think
that was a great time for him to come
out and say this is no time for
political violence let's turn down the
turn down the temperature uh but i would
say this to to uh mega republicans and
and mainstream republicans don't
underestimate joe biden this was a very
obnoxious abrasive aggressive aggressive
speech but i think he also gave the
democrats a battle cry which is
democracy and i'm sure you'd rather have
them talking about that than talking
about critical race theory uh 87 000 new
irs agents coming to torment all of us
and uh like it or not but i think it
gives them something else to talk about
and rather than you know count the
account the house seats that we've
already won we've not won anything and
the republicans need to go out there and
work very hard to win this victory
because nothing is baked in the cake yet
that's a very good point uh and governor
you know you've run some races you know
what what campaigning what politics is
like uh and they clearly expect this to
have some kind of benefit uh obviously
they won in the last election with so
much violence surrounding the
environment
do you think they're going to realize
this was a mistake or is this what we're
going to see up until the presidential
election uh beyond the midterms
tammy i think this is going to go down
in history as the speech known as the
get off my lawn speech because basically
joe biden tonight was an angry old man
yelling at the camera and yelling at 74
million americans and saying that we
don't love democracy we don't love
america that we're not honorable people
and and that's why i have horrible just
say to you is just
that revs me up to want to go vote now
i'll be honest with you i almost didn't
make it on time tonight because after
the speech i had to go take a shower to
get the spittle of joe biden off of me
i've never seen anything like it this
was the kind of speech that you would
give in the heat of a campaign you never
give this kind of speech as a president
and honestly i've never seen anything
like it
i will tell you this joe biden tonight
for a man who doesn't like fossil fuel
he used about 10 years worth of the
natural gas supply in america
gaslighting trying to project his anger
on the rest of america it it was
disgusting shocking
but you know what the reason it may work
is because he has a partner
the media and they'll be with him all
the way yeah you know charlie you're in
the media right you've got a great
newspaper the washington times you
you've got you think about your audience
you we realize that there's a diversity
of people who watch this program who
watch this network who voted for trump
uh you know who now numbers are shifting
when it comes to hispanics and
independents and libertarians because as
americans we all have the future in mind
we all care about our families we all
care about how they're being taught we
care about violence and crime and an
open border and you'd think that he
would as president want to
bring those people in it's as though
they're just throwing 70 to 80 million
people overboard not even by ignoring
them but by insulting them and
essentially threatening them am i
reading too much into that yeah
no i don't think so at all and what is
absolutely obvious from that speech
tonight is that joe biden wants to talk
about absolutely anything but those
issues and the thing that you just put
your finger on that i think is so
important is that you're right democrats
care about paying high gas prices
democrats care about
the safety of their children democrats
care about uh not
paying disastrous inflation prices at
the ga at the grocery store these are
all issues that appeal to their own
voters and so the fact that he has no
response whatsoever
cannot ca campaign on any of those
things just demonstrates how far out of
touch he is with his own voters
you know it's interesting to roy there
was a poll it was a reuters pool after
the mar-a-lago raid and after the uh
student loan you know bailout
and biden went down seven points in one
week
is is this kind of would you say this is
a panic perhaps there it's like there's
nothing they can do maybe they thought
the mar-a-lago raid would bring certain
dividends and and that you know throwing
more money at people would bring certain
dividends and that they really don't
understand the american people and they
don't understand our lives and this is
now just like the last the last hurrah
of what it is they think they can do
i think what biden probably is trying to
do is just get his base as excited as
possible and hope that the
far left democrats have been
disappointed with him because he's not
far left enough that they this might get
them excited and get them back into the
fray i mean we always heard that uh joe
biden is this great centrist this
wonderful moderate who's been kidnapped
by ron clayne and the white house staff
he's always been a leftist he's been
left just his whole career great point
he had a lifetime american conservative
union rating of just 13 percent so this
guy's a leftist and i think he's doing
what he his heart wants wants him to do
which is to peel appeal the left and
hope that will get his numbers up high
enough uh to prevent some kind of a
total destruction november you know for
any of us and i have been one of them
thinking that he had been kidnapped and
that none of this made any sense the
fact of the matter is you know uh it
does make sense that this is exactly
what he wants and it's what dr jill
wants all of them own what this is and
all of them will own what will be a
horrible
embarrassing
debilitating legacy for that entire
family and it's a shame it's an insult
to the democrats and it's an insult to
every other american in this country a
gentleman thank you for joining me
tonight i appreciate it